stop I just wanted to interrupt this
video because I need to make an
announcement did you guys see the video
I made where I celebrated a hundred
million subscribers it was the video I
was really excited about I talked about
my journey from going to zero to one
hundred million subscribers it did have
a brand attachment to it which maybe
wasn't the most fitting place but it was
a cool product so I thought it wouldn't
matter when we were planning the
collaboration we thought it would be
nice to donate to a charity as a way to
celebrate I made the mistake of picking
a charity that I was adviced instead of
picking a charity that I'm personally
passionate about which is 100% my fault
usually when I pick a charity I take my
time I find a charity that I'm really
excited about and actually passionate to
donate to so when I uploaded the video
talking about the charity it was very
brief and people could tell something
was off the whole internet just didn't
believe in like why is he donating to
this charity look at his face full of
conspiracy mode and it was very
interesting to watch that unfold to be
fair I saw it as an opportunity to put
an end to these all trite claims that
has been thrown against me it wasn't to
try and clear my name or save grace if
it was I would have done a years ago but
after the Christchurch tragedy I felt a
responsibility to do something about it
because it's no longer just about me
it affected other people in a way and
I'm not okay with that I've struggled to
figure out how to do that but this was
not the right way to go about it
I knew it wasn't perfect but I also
didn't know a lot of things that
surfaced
throughout this whole thing about the
charity that doesn't fit at all so I
understand why people had concerns about
it and these are things that I would
have known myself I had just taken my
time this whole thing was planned during
my wedding and the honeymoon and
100,000,000 was coming up as well so it
was all very rushed it really doesn't
feel genuine for me to proceed with a
donation at this point and I instead
wanted to actually do take my time keep
the intent that I had but just doing it
with the right charity
and doing it properly I just wanted to
make that clear I'm sorry for all the
confusion and I'm sorry for messing this
up that's what I do
let's get on with the video
welcome everyone to why not very epic
Marcia shell burg I just had to explain
to Felix what pop the cherry actually
means jacksepticeye I feel like I failed
him as a friend
is this what friends are for to explain
to me all this I still don't know if I
fully understand you popped the top of
the champagne hello
getting downloaded by peers wait this
got really 69,000 up boats Thank You
fields very cool getting down voted by
Puetz being one of the few people that
will ever get peers down votes I get
harassed by the community I become
famous for being hated look insert
Thanos meme I don't even know who you
are but congrats to 69 outputs that's
epic
pity pie I think I forgot something
nine-year-olds if you forgot that he
wasn't important yeah you're right 100
million brofist we've already done it
here it's a little pickle that's right
we've changed it to a bro tickle I think
it's better I think it's got potential
to ketchup obligatory
GoPro Jim I expected Vsauce 4 that's
even better very epic swen after seeing
all his friends die his husband died and
feel excluded
oh god I didn't see it that way I'm
sorry hey no huge I promised a guy a
brofist at a hundred mill I said 101
mill so that was a freaking line pickle
here you go bro tickle don't like it so
much
Jesus what's wrong with you my offer to
make you a custom hundred mill award
still stains all you have to do is say
yes mr. pie did I just say it oh my god
I mean I'd be honored
Bobby Dukes is one that made I think the
downvote play button you know I'm proud
of this yes
mr. pie what I bet
thanks to wifey for editing this so
epically everyone like that you think I
can do the do it better than Thor the
first villager to ever get a profession
must have been like it took a while
god damn I'm slow that's good good me I
just found banked on the beach hope you
like it I just had to explain fit what
does it mean what what does it made yep
meanwhile in Australia Dinnerbone oh
that makes no sense if it was named
Dinnerbone he would be upside out why is
it another skeleton horse cringe Puetz
don't forget to repair the Elantra oh I
can repair it with those the the
membranes of the flying things epic I
heard it was easier to just use mending
though so okay you caught a Felix what
that's impossible
that's literally impossible I don't even
exist in Minecraft what they added in
Felix to Minecraft that's epic then you
can sit up your butt must be hurting so
much Sven I broke my ass it happens to
the best of us at least once in your
life don't deny it reason Adam lytx
should what pity pie could pass bleep
theories in late 2022 hmm bro tickle the
fattest bro tickle will come if we met
I'm kidding I'm not playing into that
anymore but the fattest bro tickle
Maya's old now she doesn't want the same
food anymore
why is that sad she says old and sassy
she's like nah I'm not having it
screw you you've been feeding me the
same food every single day for years I
mean it's kind of understandable isn't
it
you wouldn't like eating the same food
every day you had to get however no
problem
I feel like Maya is more of a person
than than a dog sometimes cuz she she
always communicates stuff to us like if
she wants to go out she'll go to the
door
if she wants food she'll start petting
the bowl if she wants cuddles
she starts patting my face wait what is
this
you know how pewds goes like Bing bong
Bing Bing bong well I know what it means
Oh God if Bing it's one and bong is zero
it would be one zero one one zero in the
binary number system that is equal to 22
in normal numbers 22 in letters is BB if
you pronounce BB it sounds like Bab a I
think Felix is secretly telling us that
you figured me out at Hertz dude put all
of its pets in danger in one episodes 9
year olds hey how dare you say that it's
my fault I was just trying to have fun
at a tribal aid I was just try to have
fun at a trampoline
what Petey pie snake pity parties make
that's awesome
copyrighted jacksepticeye got married -
oh my god congratulations
it's a celebration I'm a little
disappointed we didn't play that song at
the at the funeral I almost said at the
mayor marriage thing I don't like cheats
that much either I feel cheated I love
cheese what kind is your favorite kind
of cheese
yes it's relevant cheese is always
relevant I like melted cheese melted
melted melted hello it's different
ah what I've seen so many of these I
actually understood the meme watching
the show understanding the basic plot
through memes yo mr. B's I bet you never
fill the pool with roses before
to peace are you challenging me that's
right mr. beast I challenge you sorry no
if I'm gonna challenge mr. beast I need
something better to challenge him come
on it's not a freaking pool full of
roses nestling it should be a pool full
with G fuel and he should drink the
whole thing hey I'm wearing the same
shirt this is the dumbest subreddit of
all time confirmed and I love it thank
you guys
I actually know where that buddies from
that's amazing you could not live with
your own failure where did that bring
you back to me i watch endgame and now I
appreciate this meme even more feels
good man and finally part of the kids
club let's pop the chit is it all about
this eye it makes more sense you popped
the cherry hello pop it makes a popping
sound hello it doesn't make a popping
sound when you free there's n so why is
it called pop the cherry explain this
scientist I want to hear it unless
you're scientists don't even bother
commenting pop sound or no pop sound
rule a burrito watching sled do a 360
over her damn what the Sheep changed
color of his council to red so he could
warn Felix about the dangers of redstone
oh my god this blow my mind in pieces oh
oh God so it's Council of water sheep
good is that what that means but the
water sheep evil I'm so confused yep
what Felix and Maya says wedding cake
must have been like yep get in the boat
Felix no Peter pie reaction to my meme
it gets to pee pee poo poos no two
people folk was really good that's
really good I understand now the
influence I have as a person that
there's another person behind the meme I
will never rate to pee pee poop once
again I'm sorry
when pewds ass would you guys freak a
creeper but realized that most creepers
are ten to twenty minutes old
yeah that's also yeah I'm freaking creep
er Bendis sexy-ass over he'd be begging
for it deeper Oh
oh man he'll go oh yeah everyone come on
that was that big let me have fun a wing
oh that's so good
portal everything at this very moment
thousands of screens broke I am living
the best life I want one of those tennis
clubs when Felix is slowly becoming
better at redstone if you're like
registered is one of those things that
looks complicated if someone else
explains it but when you do it yourself
it's so easy and basic I like I always
feel really dumb when I watch all the
people but then you put the stuff in as
I oh you make the flip-flop go but Bebop
it's simple this is brilliant but I like
this classic YouTube comments always
liking the original no matter how strict
down and she dusts never change you to
what you don't like the new intro I
wanted it to be stylized in a in a
really funky and weird way I think that
the black and white is just like it's
literally a placeholder it's funny for a
while but I don't know on that day
mankind remember oh my god damn my teeth
are freaking huge dude I imagine they
just keep going
my god me at the beginning of Peters
video me as hints of this beauty pie was
wedding big brain merch while he was
trying to figure out what a coconut was
called goddamn minecraft confuses me so
much why are they no cut if there were
coconuts in Minecraft I would have known
what it was at least if there was pop de
Hyman ill anyway said it if it was pop
big cherry ill ah oh my god that's
amazing how many of them do you think
will keep living leave your votes in the
comments now what you see through the
microscope what the back here yes
Jesus Christ that's terrifying girls
talking oh my gosh I hate my hair I hate
school uh do you like my dress boys
talking would you guys freak a creeper
leave a comment and smash liking this
video if you would freak a creeper
that's what I thought that's a tickle
that's a tickle bonus tickle em next
surprise take up this is brilliant
I like this find their taste the first
villager like a pea appeared useless
stuff mustard
get me
very good me anime characters were they
about to go crazy get crazy
that's brilliant normal people would go
pro Felix would go pred I really
appreciate the nose hair coming out I'm
really glad that was in the shot
area 51 raid is in two weeks don't
forget to bring your end there post
alright gamers you know what to do don't
forget your beds your ender pearls your
finest diamond armor and to enchant your
leggings okay let's go Amazon when your
order same-day shipping at 11:59 p.m.
apparently you can use blue eyes I don't
know how you get blue eyes but that
makes it even faster we're gonna get
blue-ice mark my work we're gonna get
blue eyes 2018 what that is so dumb
would you guys listen this is a
no-judgment zone just smash like on the
video and it'll all just move on no
one's gonna say anything
no one's gonna judge no one's gonna make
you feel bad for what you believe in
nice like being forever forgotten by
pewds oh really
okay yeah I forgot the parrot but oh
really I hope I catch a good mean
there's no fish to catch because of
climate change your life is in danger
penguin
I said fish get in the boat I said I
even said [ __ ] inhales
oh my god you can make bells with
redstone Jase is happy this person try
to unlock your phone me after remember
the cringy thing I did four years ago
I don't deserve friends why is that why
can't my brain just for not forget how
can i forget things
please brain okay I have so much
cringing material up here I can I just
remove the lis like brain sucks
marzia adding legs to every shot pewters
it can we appreciate the CGI that went
into making the blog I mean finally the
oppression and I've taught my dog to
brofist and it made me smile hope it
makes you smile too
oh the first guy who discovered science
must get me man begs water sheep for
forgiveness 2019 colorized why did I not
and whenever I watch their box I'm like
God there were so many chances for me to
mean these moments but then I realized
no okay not my entire life has to
revolve around youtube memes okay Felix
don't sit in front of your computer all
the day go outside and enjoy your
honeymoon isn't it dope oh you can use
it Wireless no come on I had to try it
I was playing peeing simulator and yes I
shat myself well you haven't tried to
personal a turd City after 50 million
our troops
don't just doubt it's still relevant
just download it